une conférence de rédaction délocaliser
dans une salle de classe la semaine de
la presse à l'école n'a jamais aussi
bien porté son nom
on imagine dès le matin à quoi pourra
ressembler le journal du lendemain
sachant que bien souvent ce qu'on a
imaginé le matin c'est pas du tout ce
qu'on aura dans le journal le lendemain
pourquoi ben parce que l'actualité à 10
heures elle n'est pas figée choix des
sujets organisation du travail les
journaliste de l'est républicain ont
dévoilé les coulisses de leur métier on
va la mettre en ouverture de séquences
parce que c'est l'information principale
de notre journée il voit la
hiérarchisation ils comprennent aussi ce
que je pense qu'ils ont pu comprendre
aussi comment comment ça se déroule à
partir de la réunion du matin qui est
effectivement une réunion importante
pour nous
commence comment va se dérouler la
journée face à la rédaction une classe
très attentive
si tous connaissent le quotidien peu le
lisent et savent comment il est fabriqué
je connaissais un peu mais ça m'a aidé à
comprendre des choses sur le métier de
journaliste pour moi c'est un métier
compliqué entre guillemets c'est faut
être attentif
il faut toujours se renseigner toujours
avoir la bonne information et pas
franchement pas se tromper
surtout la séance se déroule dans le
cadre du cours de français et l'objectif
n'est pas de susciter des vocations
c'est encore jeune pour savoir ce qu'ils
veulent faire comme métier
mais déjà apprendra à se méfier de tout
ce qu'on peut voir apprendre à réfléchir
aussi paru même et puis à être capable
de produire aussi soi-même de
l'information diane écrite le collège
jacques brel participent chaque année à
l'opération mais c'est la première fois
qu'une vraie conférence de rédaction se
tenait dans l'établissement